الامن المائي مبحث كبير وجزء لا يتجزا من
الامن القومي في اي بلد ومصر تواجه تحديات
جامه على مستوى امنها المائي لاسباب منها
ان معظم مواردها المائيه تاتي من الخارج
يزداد الامر الحاحا كلما ناقص منسوب
المياه
المتدافعين حياتها الرئيسي النيل ويدق
ناقوس الخطر بالنسبه لامن مصر المائي هذه
السنه في وقت تتعثر فيه المفاوضات
الثلاثيه بشان سد النهضه الاثيوبي وقد
اتهم وزير الري المصري الديس ابابا برفض
توقيع اتفاق عادل ومتوازن حول تعبئه السد
وتشغيله فالى اين تتجه الازمه وما مدى
تاثيرها على المشهد المصري بصوره
عامه مصر من اكثر دول العالم جفافا مفارقه
ان تمسي تلك حقيقه البلد الذي وصفه
القدماء يوما بهبه النيل لم يكن ذلك
تصريحا متشائما بعيدا عن الدرايه والتخصص
بل جاء على لسان وزير الري المصري الذي
اضاف ان
97% من موارد البلاد المائيه تاتي من
الخارج ضمن فعاليات اسبوع القاهره للمياه
الذي اتخذ من الامن المائي شعارا تطرق
محمد عبد العاطي وزير الموارد المائيه
والري لازمه سد النهضه منددا بما اعتبرها
مواقف اثيوبيه متشدده حالت دون الوصول الى
اتفاق متكامل حول ملء السد وتشغيله بما
يعد حسب الوزير تحديا اثيوبيا لدولتي
المعبر والمصب السودان ومصر ترفض اثيوبيا
بحسب الوزير المصري توقيع اتفاق عادل
ومتوازن حول السد رغم كل ما قدمته مصر
لتبديد مخاوفها في اتفاقيه المبادئ عام
2015 اللافت ان رئيس الوزراء المصري مصطفى
مدبولي اعلن خلال كلمته لاسبوع القاهره
للمياه حرص بلاده على استمرار عمليه
التفاوض مع كل من السودان واثيوبيا للوصول
الى اتفاق ملزم فهل تتواصل المفاوضات كما
يوحي تصريح رئيس الوزراء ام ان الرفض
الاثيوبي بات قاطعا كما يفهم من كلام وزير
الري وهل كان الصواب ان تتلو هذه
المفاوضات اتفاق المبادئ عام 2015 ام ان
تؤسس له وتسبقه هكذا تساءل مراقبون
منتقدين موقف النظام المصري الذي ابرم
الاتفاق المذكور دون تفاوض ولا استشارات
فنيه تبصر بالعواقب التي تشكو منها
القاهره الان يتهم الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي من قبل خصومه بما يصل لحد
تعمد تضييع حقوق مصر في مياه النيل لسوء
ادارته للملف فقد سبق له تبشير مواطنيه
بحفظ حقوقهم بل نهى عن الكلام في الموضوع
مراعاه لمشاعر الاثيوبيين ويذكر له
المصريون مشهد حمل رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي
على الحلف بالله الا يضر مصر في
مياهها مع بدء المرحله الاولى لملء خزان
السد قبل اشهر خرجت تصريحات من ادس ابابا
تتحدث عن تحول النيل لبحيره وتوقفه عن
الجريان ولم ترد عليها القاهره وتجدد
الحديث الاثيوبي في الايام القليله
الماضيه على لسان رئيس الحكومه ومن قبله
رئيسه الجمهوريه بان البلاد ستبدا توليد
الكهرباء من السد خلال عام وان المرحله
الثانيه لملء الخزان ستبدا في موعدها في
اغسطس من العام المقبل وان السد سيحتج
فيها اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف ما احتجزه في
المرحله
الاولى هل بقي بيد القاهره شيء من اوراق
ضغط يمكن ان تحمل الى ادس ابابا على
التفاوض وصولا لقواعد ملزمه تراعي مصالح
دولتي المعبر والمصب كما يرجو المسؤولون
المصريون لحل ازمه يرونها من اهم ركائز
امنهم
القومي نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من
القاهره مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير صحيفه
المشهد الاسبوعيه من ادس ابابا حالي يحيى
حالي الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ومن اسطنبول
جمال سلطان الكاتب الصحفي المصري اهلا بكم
جميعا وابدا معك مجدي شندي من القاهره ما
هي المعطيات التي استجدت في هذا الملف حتى
يخرج وزير الر المصري بتصريحات ينتقد فيها
الاثيوبيين بانهم يحولون الان دون التوصل
الى اتفاق عادل ومتوازن حول ملء سد النهضه
وتشغيله
يعني كانت المناسبه هي
عقد مؤتمر يسمى اسبوع القاهره ل المياه
وهذا المؤتمر تحضره اطراف اوروبيه واطراف
دوليه فراى الجانب المصري ان هذا المؤتمر
يمثل فرصه
لمحاوله اقناع المشاركين
باحقيه مصر في مطالبتها باتفاق عادل وا
اتفاق قانوني ملزم لكل الاطراف
وتنبيه المجتمع الدولي
ومره ثانيه بان هذا التعند الاثيوبي قد
يقود الى
وضع المنطقه في حاله حرجه قد
تسبب
يعني ازمه فيما يتعلق
بالسلم والامن العالميين لان مصر لن تقبل
باتفاق منقوص ولن تقبل بان يجور احد على
حقوقها حيث ان المياه بالنسبه لمصر تمثل
حياه او موت ومصر قد بذلت كل ما تستطيع ع
وتركت الحبل على الغارب لكل المناورات
الاثيوبيه امله ان تصل في النهايه الى
اتفاق عادل ومنصف
يضم مصر والسودان كما يضمن مصالح اثيوبيا
في الوقت نفسه معنى ذلك ان ما تضمنته
تصريحات وزير الرا المصري كانت رسائل
للمجتمع الدولي اكثر من غيره ما الذي فعله
المجتمع الدولي في فترات التفاوض الاخيره
ما الذي فعله عندما ذهبت اثيوبيا الى
الملء الاول لخزان سد النهضه حتى يفعله
الان يعني في كل
الاحوال يعني من المهم جدا ان
يقتنع المجتمع الدولي باحقيه المطالب
المصريه حتى اذا ما احيل ا الموضوع الى
مجلس الامن او عاد لمجلس الامن مره ث انيه
اذا فشل الاتحاد الافريقي في مهمته وهذا
امر متوقع واو اذا عرض على محكمه العدل
الدوليه او جرى اي يعني تفاوض باشراف يعني
اطراف دوليه
يكون تكون وجهه النظر المصريه قد وصلت الى
المجتمع الدولي كامله غير منقوصه وهذا عم
المفاوض المصري نريد ان نسمع من ضيفنا من
اديس بابا حالي يحيى حالي يقول اذا وزير
الرا المصري ان اثيوبيا متشدده في موضوع
التوصل الى اتفاق وهي التي تحول دون
التوصل اليه الم تحل فعلا اثيوبيا دون
التوصل الى اتفاق عندما سارعت الى الملء
الاول لخزان السد في عز جولات التفاوض
التي كانت مازالت تبحث في الامور الفنيه
والتقنيه
للموضوع
شكرا جزيلا على
الاستضافه ارجو يعني تسمح لي ارد اولا على
التعليق الاخ مجدي شندي حينما قال ان مصر
اذا كانت حريصه على اتفاق غير منقوص ايضا
بحسب الراي العام هنا في اثيوبيا اثيوبيا
تسعى على يعني تحقيق اتفاق عادل واعاده
للحصص العادله للمياه في يعني ولا تعترف
الاتفاقيات السابقه واثيوبيا منذ الوهله
الاولى منذ عامين عام 2011 دابت ويعني
كانت اشد التزاما
بتحقيق التوافقات السياسيه والفنيه
الثلاثيه بين الاطراف الثلاثه لكن ربما
هناك يعني حتى هذه اللحظه هناك عدم ثقه
يعني اثيوبيا ترى ان مصر ما زالت لا تثق
في الخطوات التي تقدم عليها اثيوبيا والمل
الاولي في اواخر شهر اغسطس الماضي كما
يعني كانت الطبيعه هي التي ادت الى الملء
بهذه الطريقه والان كما نعلم ان رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد خلال زيارته
لسد النهضه قبل ايام قال ان ان المره
القادمه خلال العام المقبل ستكون هناك
عمليه الم ستكون ثلاثه اضعاف المرحله
الاوليه
ا يعني يعني بهذا الحديث يؤكد يؤكد على
انه الميات
رساله لبناء الثقه بين الدول الثلاث كيف
يمكن بناء هذه الثقه في ظل المعطيات
الحاليه في ظل حديث الديس ابابا الان عن
ملئ ثان للسد خلال اقل من عام في اغسطس
القادم بثلاثه اضعاف ما تمت تعبئته في
الملء الاول وكذلك استخدام السد لتوليد
الكهرباء كيف يمكن ان تحصل على هذه الثقه
او ان ترسل اشارات ثقه للطرفين الاخرين
السودان
ومصر بناء على نتائج الملء الاولي حينما
راينا ان اثيوبيا حينما يعني الطبيعه ايضا
ساعدتها في الملء الاولي وراينا النتائج
يعني بحسب الموقف الاثيوبي هنا يعني يعني
مل السد يعني هناك كان اختلاف انه اثيوبيا
كانت تريد ان تملا السد في ما بين ثلاثه
الى اربعه اوام ومصر كانت تصر على ان يكون
من سبعه الى 10 الان اثيوبيا ترى انه من
المناسب ان تتعجل في في الملء الثاني خلال
العام المقبل لتضمن مل السد وانتاج
الكهرباء ايضا هناك يعني بحسب ما ما عليه
الان الوضع في اثيوبيا هناك رغبه في
التجربه الاولى لتوليد الكهرباء لا اعتقد
ان هناك ضررا كبيرا سيقع على مصر في في
مساله الملء
الثاني واعتقد ان اثيوبيا ايضا لها يعني
هناك ضمانات تستطيع ان تقدمها لمصر من قبل
المجتمع الدولي الذي تسعى اليه ايضا
القاهره لتحقيق متحدث عن نوع هذه
الضمانات عندما نحصل من ضيفنا من اسطنبول
جمال سلطان على تعليق عما يحدث الان من
تجاذبات بين مصر واثيوبيا من يتحمل
مسؤوليه هذا الانسداد الذي وصل اليه هذا
الملف تعثر في المفاوضات تشدد من الاطراف
واثيوبيا ماضيه في مخطط مل
الد هو يعني يعني بطبيعه الحال وانا بدون
اي تكلف ولا تزيد يعني تتحمل القياده
المصريه المسؤوليه الكامله عن ما ال اليه
هذا الوضع لم يحدث في تاريخ مصر الحديث
بكامله ان كانت مصر عندما تبحث في مساله
ملف النيل او تبحث عن النيل تلجا الى
المجتمع الدولي و يعني تتلمس العون من
المجتمع الدولي وتقدم ال الاعزار وتقدم
التوضيحات للمجتمع لم يحدث ذلك ابدا انما
كانت مصر لها قرار ولها اراده والجميع
يحترمون هذه الاراده المصريه الان رئيس
الجمهوريه نفسه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
لا يخاطب لا يخاطب الطرف لا يظهر لكي
يخاطب الطرف الاثيوبي يعني رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي ابي احمد كل فتره بيخرج يخاطب
شعبه ويخاطب المجتمع الدولي ويخاطب ايضا
مصر وكل من المعنيين بهذا
الملف بخططه بافكاره بارادته السياسيه
الرئيس السيسي لم يفعل ذلك ابدا عندما
يريد ان يتحدث عن ازمه سد النهضه اذا تحدث
يعني في مرات نادره انما يتحدث الى الشعب
المصري ويتحدث في الشعب المصري بروح اللي
هو اخلاء المسؤوليه ليس بروح القائد الذي
يتحمل المسؤوليه ب ربما تشير الان سيد
جمال سلطان الى جزئيه مرتبطه بالمسؤوليه
السياسيه اكثر من غيرها
ماذا عن التفاصيل الفنيه والتقنيه
المرتبطه بهذا المشروع اين اخطات مصر اذا
اخذنا بكلامك بان القياده المصريه هي التي
تتحمل الدرجه الاولى من
المسؤوليه اخطات في اخطات خطا فادحا
بالتوقيع على اتفاقيه 2015 لانه لم يكن
اتفاقيه غامضه وفضفضه واعتبرها الطرف
الاثيوبي انها تبيح له ملء السد ولا تفرض
عليه اي شروط ولا اي قواعد بل تعطيه حق
فيه ان هو اثناء التفاوض واثناء المباحثات
يقوم بملء السد واعلن ذلك صراحه ولم يجرؤ
الطرف المصري على ان ينفيه ولا وزير
الخارجيه المصري نفاه ايضا حديث السيسي عن
انه انه لا توجد مشكله من الاساس يعني لما
كان يسال في ذلك الوقت عن مشكله سد النهض
عن مشكله المياه الازمه لا يوجد ازمه لا
يوجد مشكله من حيث الاسا كيف لا يوجد
مشكله وكل هذه الدنيا ومصر الان بلدك
معرضه للخطر 100 مليون واحد 100 مليون
انسان ال ضيفنا من القاهره سيد مجدي شندي
عما تقوله سيد جمال سلطان مجدي شندي اذا
مسؤوليه مصر في هذا الموضوع عندما ذهب
السيسي الى التوقيع على اتفاق المبادئ عام
2015 ومنح الاثيوبيين مفتاح التحكم في هذا
الملف في سد النهضه وفي حصص مصر المائيه
الا يتحمل بذلك المسؤوليه
هو يعني فيما يتعلق بملف حساس مثل ملف
مياه
النيل يعني هناك حزم مصر مصري تاريخي في
هذا الملف لم تكن ابدا مصر تسمح
بان يعني توضع لبنه واحده في سد دون
استشارتها الذي حدث ان اثيوبيا استغلت ما
شهدته مصر من انشغال بالداخل في بعد قيام
ثوره 25 يناير 2011 وبدات في بناء السد
وللاسف الشديد يعني ساندتها اطراف عربيه
من بينها السعوديه والامارات و قطر كانهم
يعني حين يفعلون ذلك يريدون الادراب بمصر
من
حيث لا يريدون وبتال يعني سيد مجدي شندي
انت تلوم انت تلوم انت تلوم الديس ابابا
لانها ذهبت في خطط مل السد ولا تلوم مصر
التي منحتها تلك الامكانيه بالتوقيع على
اتفاق المبادئ عام
2015 يعني اتفاق المبادئ في حد ذاته لم
يكن يعني اعطاء تفويض لاثيوبيا لكن وجهه
النظر الشعبيه المصريه ان مصر كان ينبغي
ان تكون اكثر حزما دليل عدم تفريط القياده
المصريه هو رفضها ل توقيع اي اتفاق منقوص
حتى هذه اللحظه واصرارها على حقوق مصر
كامله بعيدا عن التلاوم اريد ان ارد فقط
على ضيفك الاثيوبي الذي يتحدث عن موضوع
الاتفاقات السابقه اثيوبيا دائما ما تحاول
خلط الاوراق كانها حين تتفاوض على تشغيل
سد النهضه
وطريقه الملء تتحدث
يعني من جانب اخر عن اعاده تقسيم المياه
هذا
ليس امرا مطروحا مساله اعاده تقسيم المياه
مره اخرى ليعلم الطرف الاثيوبي ذلك ولا
ينبغي ان يخلط الاوراق ب س ضيفنا من اديس
ابابا سيد مجدي الشندي لو سمحت لي سيد
حالي يحيى حالي الثقه التي وضعها المصريون
في الاثيوبيين عندما وقعوا على اتفاق
المبادئ عام 2015
يقول كثيرون ان اديس بابا استغلته لصالحها
ولم تكترث للضرر الذي يمكن ان يلحقه ذلك
بالامن المائي لمصر وللسودان ايضا الا
يضعها ذلك في حرج مواجهه ما يمكن ان يقدم
عليه المجتمع الدولي اذا ضغطت مصر اكثر في
اتجاه استقدامه للتدخل اكثر في هذا
الملف اولا اختي الكريمه الاخ مج شندي مع
احترامي الكبير له يقلل من شان الخبير
المائي المصري حينما يعني حينما يستشار في
امر يعني قومي مثل المياه يعني السيد
الرئيس السيسي يستعين بخبراء مصريين في في
مثل هذه المسائل لذلك يعني ليس من من
الانصاف التقليل بشان الخبراء المصريين
الذين كانوا يتابعون يعني بناء السد منذ
عام
2011 لكن اذا كانت مصر عام 2011 لها شان
داخلي ويقولون ان اثيوبيا استقلت الوضع
ايضا هناك كانت تحديات في اثيوبيا لكن
اثيوبيا اتخذت موقف واضح من اتفاقيه اعلان
المبادئ في مارس عام 2015 وكانت المنطلق
الحقيقي والسند الحقيقي لها فيما وصلت
اليه الان من البناء الذي وصل الى حوالي
75% والان اذا كانت هناك اتفاقيات تمت بين
الاطراف الثلاثه في حوالي
95% الباقي الان 5% في نقاط فنيه وقانونيه
ولماذا الاخ مجدي يتحدث باسم السودان
السودان دوله لها سياده وله اهله ما الذي
فعلته اثيوبيا في هذه الجوانب الفنيه
والتقنيه سيد حالي يحي حال في التعثر
الفني والتقني الذي يحدث في جولات التفاوض
حتى الان ما الذي قدمته اديس ابابا لحل
المساله يعني اثيوبيا
بحسب اثيوبيا بحسب ما هو عليه الواقع وانا
انقل هنا الواقع على الشارع الاثيوبي يعني
كانت اكثر حرصا ل يعني تعزيز الاتفاق الذي
تم بين الاطراف الثلاثه في عام 2015 وهو
المرجع الرئيسي لكن ا يعني الاتفا يعني
يعني في الفتره الاخيره حينما ذهبت يعني
مصر الى الولايات المتحده واستعانت
بالمجتمع الدولي كان من الاحرا ترى
اثيوبيا كان من الاحرى ان تاتي مصر الى
الاتحاد الافريقي الذي هو والاتحاد الايقي
لم ي الان
حتى اطراف التفاوض الى طاوله المفاوضات
سيد جمال سلطان سيناريوهات حل هذه
الازمه اين تكمن الان هناك طرف اقوى من
اخر اثيوبيا الان في موقع اقوى من مصر كيف
يمكن اذا ان تحل برضى الاطراف
كلها لا هي مثل هذه الامور لا تكون الا
بالتوافق بين بين دول حوض النيل بالكامل
لكن لا نستطيع ان نقول مع احترام الكامل
لاثيوبيا قياده وشعبا الا انه لا نستطيع
ان نقول ان اثيوبيا في موقع قوه او موقع
سيطره هي تريد ان تفرض وضعا جديدا تتحاكم
او توظف به قضيه النيل اجواء سياسيه اخرى
لكن المساله تعود الى القياده السياسيه
المصريه يعني مساله ان هو لابد ان يخرج
السيسي من اطار اللي هو البحث عن مشجب عن
شما يعلق عليها الفشل السيسي من 2000
حكايه تحميل ثوره يناير ثوره يناير 2011
2014 كان السيسي يتحكم في مصر ويسيطر على
مصر السيطره كامله جيش وشرطه وقضاء
واقتصاد وخارجيه وداخليه وكل شيء سبع
سنوات ماذا فعلت فيها تحمل مسؤوليتك
بشجاعه في مثل هذه الامور التي يتعرض فيها
الامن القومي لاشد اشد وجوه الخطر من حياه
المصريين نفسهم الشعب اصبح في خطر لابد ان
يكون هناك القائد يظهر ويحدد نقاط ويحدد
نقاط حمراء يعني اذا كنت انت وضعت علامات
حمراء او خطوط حمراء ل في الجيش الليبي
عند حدود سرت على بعد اكثر من 1000 كيلو
منك في عمق الصحراء فلماذا لا تضع هنا
خطوط خطوط حمراء ايضا في في امنك القومي
في صميم لابد ان يكون هناك رؤيه ولابد ان
يكون هناك خطوط واضحه حتى يطمئن حتى الشعب
المصري لانه قيادته يعني تبحث تحمي حياه
الشعب وتحمي المستقبل اشكرك جمال سلطان
كاتب الصحفي المصري من اسطنبول حالي يحيى
حالي الصحفي والمحلل السياسي من ادي سبابا
ومجدي شندي رئيس تحرير صحيفه المشهد
الاسبوعيه من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا وشكرا لمتابعتكم حصاد الليله الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء